le pregunto ante este nuevo anuncio y
dada la ventaja con la que ya contaba
Podemos esperar una victoria de erdogan
o la oposición mantiene posibilidades
no Así es Buenas tardes desde aquí desde
Montevideo rosa para ti y para toda la
audiencia de France 24 creo que
realmente estamos viendo ya una victoria
casi cantada de él que lleva ya dos
décadas como decís al inicio del espacio
informativo erdogan va a conseguir los
casi 3 millones de votos que obtuvo
china no gana el tercero en disputa no
por la carrera presidencial con lo cual
todo hace pensar que el próximo 28 de
mayo Los Seguidores de sinalogan van a
secundar su pedido de votar a favor de
la alianza que Encarna o que representa
erdogan y Susana por otro lado pues eso
no todavía quedan unos días hasta el
domingo en qué ejes temáticos se van a
centrar estas últimas jornadas tanto de
la campaña de erdogan como de la de
kilisaroglu Bueno realmente sabemos que
la línea rojas que le ha impuesto sin
anogan para darle su apoyo a erdogan son
dos por un lado ilegalizar el partido
democrático del pueblo El que es de
extracción prácticamente kurda y también
de izquierdas un partido integrado tanto
por aquellos que se dicen progresistas y
sobre todo extracción kurda los que
quiere legalizar sin ogan y por otro
lado también devolver a casi 4,5
millones de refugiados sirios que están
habitando en Turquía desde el inicio de
las hostilidades y del conflicto sirio
hace ya 12 años devolverlos a Siria
habrá que ver si erdogan puede cumplir
esa promesa sinalogan porque recordemos
que tiene un acuerdo muy beneficioso en
cuanto al dinero que recibe de la Unión
Europea por ser un gendarme por ser
quien retenga a los refugiados sirios
para que no continúen su viaje hasta
llegar a Europa con lo cual yo creo que
esas dos líneas van a ser importantes en
estos días de discurso Y seguramente el
candidato
va a intentar de alguna manera era
hacerle pisar en falso erdogan para que
se proclame Al respecto porque no es un
discurso tan antiingratorio Como por
ejemplo lo tenía erdogan antes de
aliarse ahora con sinanogan Rosa Si
Susana y le pregunto entiendo que es una
cuestión compleja Pero brevemente cómo
se explicaría que erdogan se mantuviera
en el poder tras dos décadas No ya en
ankara a pesar de la crisis económica
que atraviesa el país desde los últimos
años bueno porque hay que entender que
es un presidente neotomanista y además
yo creo que apuestan a la baza como
Putin en Rusia son Herederos tanto
erdogan como Putin de lo que fue el
Imperio otomano y Putin por ejemplo del
imperio ruso con lo cual tienen esa
mentalidad de devolver la grandeza a
Turquía y es un es un presidente muy
nacionalista que ha sabido cooptar a
élites financieras en el país pero que
sobre todo además ha apostado a una
retórica islamista que a muchos también
les encaja bien con lo cual es un
presidente que ha ido ganando no solo
confianza del pueblo sino que además se
ha ido arrogando muchísimos poderes
sobre todo ha ido controlando a los
medios estatales controlando a los
medios periodísticos y eso ha hecho que
además desde el 2016 desde lo que fue el
nunca ha aclarado golpe de estado en su
contra pues evidentemente inició una
deriva autoritaria que le otorga una
ventaja Frente a cualquier otro
candidato opositor a él